you know what I mean he's like that guy
and I could like you know I I have to
decide whether I'm gonna ask him or not
whatever happens
you're ready
congratulations on the movie thank you
my first question is for Chris based on
this character of yours and your
previous roles as like Steve Trevor and
Captain Kirk you seem to gravitate
towards like the extraordinary ordinary
hero why is that so it's the kind of
archetype in here that I I grew up
watching and it reminds me a lot of
Harrison Ford who was kind of my when I
was a little boy looking up at the
screen he was the guy that I looked up
to and it was always like Harrison's the
president and the planes going down he's
an archaeologist or you know he was
never a caped guy with extraordinary
powers and I think I like a guy that can
like take a punch and it hurts but he
still gets up and tries to to win the
day Harrison is Iconic I'll just give
you that
that's a good icon uh Michelle I hear
you've been playing DND for years one
did you expect yourself to be casted in
a movie like this and two see yourself
play about area now are there any other
classes you would have wanted to play
well to be fair like I only played for
like three years when I was a teenager
but it definitely stayed in my mind and
and all of that all of that imagination
that stimulated came all right back to
me when we when we kind of broke the ice
together and played a game of d d with
the cast you know I gotta say it just I
just love I love that role-playing World
um but you know I don't I don't get to
live that that much you know and it was
really cool to kind of embody it uh once
again because I don't have crowds of of
uh buddies like I did when I was a
teenager in Jersey City you know what I
mean like you need like a good six
people to play and have a good time you
know to be fair I don't know enough
Geeks to pull that off these days but
hopefully we can get another game going
with John and Jonathan as dungeon
Masters oh that would be fun here at
geek culture we've tested plenty of
chairs but Secret Life gaming chairs
remain in one of our favorites whether
it's for work or play they feel great to
lean back against with the ergonomic
features offering support for the whole
body from the head
and back
to the arms and even something for your
butt this makes a format function helps
the Titan Evo 2020 to deliver the best
seating experience like no other for
more information check out secretlab.co
now both your characters are an
interesting pair because their
personalities and strengths are so
different yet they complement each other
very well how much of that is an
extension of your real life chemistry I
guess my answer to that question is like
edgkin is a lot of me you know no
discernible skills other than acting
which hopefully I can do a little bit
but Michelle's been saying that you know
Hogan's like herself so they definitely
did a good job in in matching characters
with the humans and then we just happen
to really get along as human beings in
real life so that kind of you know it's
a match made in in cinema Heaven yeah I
love that now Michelle
um your character and you know zinc are
like the most physical fighters in a
showdown between the two who will win I
would have to say zinc would probably
let me win because I'm a girl that's
what I think that's what I think I think
he's just so Noble he would put down his
sword he was yeah I will not fight you
yeah you know what I mean he's like that
guy
and I could like you know I
I be you know one of those duels that
gets stuck in this position where he
doesn't want to fight me that's what I
think would happen
[Music]
I wanna
do